[Music]
so
hi i'm george moats and i won't stop
until
everyone appreciates the american
hamburger season four
we made it even i'm amazed by that
barbecue sauce we've got so much ground
to cover this season
we've got classic burgers in the midwest
college town favorites we have a special
guest this season what an eating
experience this has been
wait whoa we've got international icons
that will make you say
that's a hamburger jalapenos are hot
they're hot they're good i promise not
to burn myself once this entire season
we had things made for the show science
louie's lunch i'm coming for you
that's how excited i am
oh yeah i'm alive
burger boys spicy boys burger scholar
session season four
with me george moats
hi i'm george moats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe
and watch more episodes right here
somewhere here
right here up in here